AMONG.
SOMETHING TO BE GRATEFUL FOR.
NOW WHAT’S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY TONIGHT, LAST WEEK WE
INTERVIEWED A LONG TIME PARTNER
THE CONSULTING FIRM.
LIKE SO MANY IN FINANCING,
WALKER SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF HIS
TIME DOING BUSINESS IN CHINA.
WE DO KNOW THEY INTERNALIZED A
LOT OF THE ATTITUDES OF CHINA’S
TOTALITARIAN GOVERNMENT.
DURING OUR INTERVIEW, WE ASKED
WALKER WHAT HE THOUGHT OF
CHINA’S LOCKDOWN.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
CREDIBLE REPORTS SUGGEST CHINESE
AUTHORITIES LOCKED PEOPLE IN THE
APARTMENTS AND LET THEM TO DIE.
AT THAT IS A QUARANTINE THAT YOU
THINK THEY DESERVE HIGH PRAISE
FOR.
WHY?
>> I THINK, LOOK AT THE RESULTS.
I KNOW THERE’S ALWAYS GOING TO
BE QUESTIONS ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
THE NUMBERS ARE.
BUT I THINK THE HARSH ACTION
THAT THEY TOOK, GIVEN THE SCALE
AND THE NUMBER OF BIG CITIES WAS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEEDED TO DO.
THE REALITY IS, THE OUTBREAK
HASN’T GONE MUCH BEYOND WUHAN.
>> Tucker: IT’S OF THE SECRET
POLICE KIDNAPPING, AUTHORITIES
LOCKING PEOPLE IN THEIR
APARTMENTS UNTIL THEY START,
LET’S LOOK AT THE RESULTS.
ALL OF THAT, WALKER SAID,
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEEDED TO DO.
THIS IS THE VIEW OF ONE OF
AMERICA’S MOST PROMINENT
BUSINESS LEADERS.
HE DIDN’T SEEM ASHAMED TO SAY
IT.
LATER IN OUR INTERVIEW, HE
SUGGESTED AMERICAN AUTHORITIES
COULD’VE DONE THE SAME THING AS
NEW YORK, IF ONLY THEY’D GOTTEN
AN EARLIER START.
YOUR JAW DROPPED WATCHING IT.
HERE’S THE STRIKING THING,
NOBODY SEEMED TO NOTICE THAT HE
SAID IT.
WALKER DIDN’T FIND HIMSELF ON
THE FRONT PAGE OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR TO NO
ONE IN AMERICAN BUSINESS
DENOUNCED HIM.
HE WENT HOME TO BED, AND THAT
WAS IT.
IF TOTALITARIANISM DOES NOT
SHOCK US ANYMORE.
MAYBE THAT’S BECAUSE ALL OF A
SUDDEN, IT’S ALL AROUND US.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS TAPE
ALREADY, IF NOT YOU’VE SEEN IT
MORE LIKE IT IN THE PAST FEW
WEEKS.
THE TWO ARMED OFFICERS ARRIVE AT
A FAMILY’S HOME IN WISCONSIN,
SOMEONE IS REPORTED THAT MOTHER
TO POLICE FOR ARRANGING UP A
DATE FOR HER DAUGHTER.
IF THAT’S NOW A CRIME.
HERE’S WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT WERE AT A
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER RIGHT NOW?
>> OBVIOUSLY.
I’M AWARE.
>> YOU’RE AWARE OF THAT?
>> WHY ARE YOU HERE?
BECAUSE YOUR DAUGHTER IS GOING
TO PLAY OTHER PEOPLE’S HOME,
YOU’RE ALLOWING IT TO HAPPEN.
STOP HAVING YOUR KID GO BY OTHER
PEOPLE’S HOMES.
>> WERE NOT.
THE MIDDLE INITIAL IN YOUR LAST
NAME.
>> I’M NOT GIVING IT TO YOU.
I HAVEN’T DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
IF >> THAT WILL BE DOCUMENTED,
TOO, THAT YOU WERE UNCOOPERATIVE
UNCOOPERATIVE.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE
UNCOOPERATIVE, THAT WILL BE
DOCUMENTED.
TO NOTICE THE TONE THAT THEY
STRIKE.
THEY ARE STANDING ON HER
PROPERTY, UNINVITED, HECTORING
HER ABOUT THE SO-CALLED CRIME OF
ALLOWING HER DAUGHTER TO PLAY
OUTSIDE OF THE HOUSE.
THEY’RE NOT APOLOGIZING, THEY’RE
NOT EMBARRASSED TO BE CARRYING
OUT AN ORDER THAT HAS NO BASIS
IN SCIENCE, THEY ARE UTTERLY,
THEY TREAT HER WITH YOUR
CONTEMPT LIKE A PEASANT.
IT LATER THE COUNTY SHERIFF’S
DEPARTMENT POSTED AN ACCOUNT OF
WHAT HAPPENED ON THEIR FACEBOOK
PAGE.
IN IT THEY REFERRED TO THAT
MOTHER’S MOBILE HOME SIX TIMES.
JUST A PEASANT, WHO CARES WHAT
SHE THINKS RIGHT?
THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO DO THAT.
THE QUESTION IS, WHERE DO THEY
GET THAT RIGHT?
THAT’S GOOD QUESTION.
IT’S A QUESTION THAT WE ARE
STRONGLY DISCOURAGED FROM
ASKING.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS, GOVERNORS
TOLD THEM THEY COULD.
NEVER, IN AMERICAN HISTORY HAVE
POLITICIANS BEEN MORE POWERFUL
THAN THEY ARE NOW.
EFFECTIVELY, THEY ARE GODS.
IN THE STATE OF MAINE, FOR
EXAMPLE, GOVERNORATE NOW HAS THE
POWER TO SUSPEND ANY LAW SHE
DOESN’T LIKE.
SHE CAN SEIZE ANY STATE RESOURCE
SHE FEELS LIKE SEIZING.
SHE CAN FORCE ANY CITIZEN, OR
ALL CITIZENS FROM THEIR HOME.
SHE CAN DO ALL OF THIS FOR AS
LONG AS SHE WANTS, AS LONG AS
SHE BELIEVES MAINE IS IN A STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT JANET
MILLS CAN’T NOW DO.
MANY GOVERNORS NOW HAVE THESE
POWERS.
IF ON MONDAY, HE DID HIS BEST TO
DESCRIBE WHY HIS WORD IS NOW LAW
IN THE STATE.
IT HAS TO BE LAW, OTHERWISE
THOUSANDS WOULD DIE.
>> THE STAY-AT-HOME ORDER HAS
PREVENTED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ILLNESSES AND THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS.
HISTORY WILL REMEMBER THOSE WHO
PUT POLITICS ASIDE TO COME
TOGETHER TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
IT WILL ALSO REMEMBER THOSE WHO
SO BLINDLY DEVOTED TO IDEOLOGY
AND THE PURSUIT OF PERSONAL
CELEBRITY THAT THEY MADE AN
ENEMY OF SCIENCE.
>> Tucker: IN THREE SENTENCES,
GOVERNOR FRAME TO HIMSELF AS THE
LEADER OF HISTORIC STATUE.
THOSE WHO DOUBT HIS DECREES ARE
"ENEMIES" OF THE SCIENCE AND
REASON.
ENEMIES OF CIVILIZATION ITSELF,
ENEMIES OF THE STATE.
IT TWO DAYS LATER, ON WEDNESDAY,
IT EMERGED THAT HIS OWN WIFE,
WHO HAS HER OWN STATE EMPLOYEES
WAS ONE OF THESE TO BE PEOPLE.
HIS WIFE, APPARENTLY HAD
VIOLATED THE LOCKDOWN HERSELF.
IF HERE’S HOW HE RESPONDED.
>> WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
STATE AT HOME ORDER AREN’T BEING
ABIDED BY YOUR FAMILY SAYING
THAT SHE RECENTLY TRAVELED TO
FLORIDA.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO SAY
THAT IN POLITICS, IT USED TO BE
THAT WE KEPT OUR FAMILIES OUT OF
IT.
MY OFFICIAL DUTIES HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH MY FAMILY.
I’M JUST NOT GOING TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
IT’S INAPPROPRIATE.
I FIND IT REPREHENSIBLE,
HONESTLY, THAT YOU THAT REPORTER
WROTE A STORY ABOUT IT.
>> YEAH, HOW DARE SOMEONE COVER
THAT PERIOD OF WHETHER OR NOT
HIS OWN FAMILY IS OBEYING THE
ORDER THAT YOUR FAMILY IS
MORALLY OBLIGATED TO FOLLOW IS
INAPPROPRIATE.
HE SAYS IT IS REPREHENSIBLE, HOW
DARE YOU?
IT WOULD BE VERY USEFUL IN TIMES
LIKE THIS TO HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
MEDIA.
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS EXIST TO HOLD
THE POWERFUL TO ACCOUNT HERE WE
HAVE THE POWERFUL ACTING WITH NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AT ALL.
OUR NEWS MEDIA, THEY ARE
CHEERING IT ON.
NO ABUSE IS TOO GROTESQUE FOR
THEM.
NO TALKING POINT IS TOO STUPID
TO REPEAT.
IT REPORTERS WILL DO WHATEVER
THEY ARE TOLD.
THEY ARE ALL IN.
MSNBC RECENTLY SENT A CAMERA
CREW TO DOCUMENT NEW
DEVELOPMENTS.
PARKING DRONES THAT HARANGUING
CITIZENS BY THE AIR.
IT MSNBC WAS DELIGHTED BY.
>> NEW JERSEY IS NOW USING
DRONES TO SPREAD THE LIFE-SAVING
MESSAGE.
>> Tucker: TO MOVE AWAY FROM
EACH OTHER COMMANDS THE STATE OF
NEW JERSEY.
IT’S YOUR GOD GIVEN RIGHT
SUSPENDED INDEFINITELY.
BACK INSIDE, OR YOU WILL FACE
THE CONSEQUENCES.
MSNBC APPLAUDS THIS, AS IF IT’S
ALL COMPLETELY NORMAL.
HANDMAIDENS TO THE CORONA
SECURITY STATE.
TO THEIR CREDIT, AT LEAST MSNBC
PUT IT ON TELEVISION.
MOST OUTLETS DON’T EVEN BOTHER
TO COVER STORIES LIKE THIS.
IF THE OTHER DAY PROSECUTORS IN
NEW JERSEY CHARGED NINE PEOPLE
FOR DARING TO PARTICIPATE IN A
JEWISH WEDDING IN THEIR
BACKYARD.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, THAT WOULD’VE
MADE THE NEWS.
FOR 250 YEARS, AMERICANS HAVE
ENJOYED THE RIGHT TO PRACTICE
THEIR FAITH AS THEY CHOOSE.
NOW THEY DON’T.
IT HAPPENED OVERNIGHT.
LAST MONTH, CHRISTIANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WERE LEGALLY
PROHIBITED FROM CELEBRATING
EASTER IN THEIR OWN CHURCHES.
THE NATIONAL MEDIA BARELY NOTED
IT.
IF HOW EXACTLY IS THIS
HAPPENING?
TURNS OUT OUT, THAT’S NOT CLEAR.
NOT MANY PEOPLE HAVE ASKED.
POLITICIANS HAVE NO RIGHT TO DO
ANY OF THIS.
THEY CANNOT MAKE IT ILLEGAL FOR
PEOPLE TO GO TO RELIGIOUS
SERVICES.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITS THAT.
AT THE WORDS COULD NOT BE
CLEARER.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT EXPLICITLY
PREVENTS GOVERNMENT FROM MAKING
ANY LAW THAT INHIBITS THE
EXERCISE OF RELIGIOUS FAITH.
THAT’S NOT A DETAIL OR FOOTNOTE,
IT IS A CORNERSTONE OF OUR
HISTORY AND LEGAL SYSTEM.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, PROBABLY
YOUR ANCESTORS LEAD TO THIS
COUNTRY FROM AROUND THE WORLD
PRECISELY BECAUSE OUR BILL OUR
BILL OF RIGHTS GAVE THEM THIS
GUARANTEE.
IT’S WHY THIS COUNTRY WAS
FOUNDED.
IN A MOMENT, IT’S GONE.
HOW?
WHERE DID POLITICIANS GET THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS?
BECAUSE SOME ELDERLY POWER DRUNK
EPIDEMIOLOGIST TOLD THEM TO DO
IT QUESTION MIKE THAT’S NOT HOW
OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
IT CAN’T WORK THAT WAY.
OCCASIONALLY, HEAR SOMEONE
COMPLAIN ABOUT THIS, SOME LONELY
THREAT THAT WE MAY BE ON A
SLIPPERY SLOPE TOWARD LOSING OUR
RIGHTS, IF ONLY.
WERE ALREADY THERE.
WE’VE SLID TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT
SLOPE.
OUR RIGHTS ARE GONE.
IF NO ONE HAS EXPLAINED HOW
POLITICIANS ARE ALLOWED TO DO
THIS.
WHERE IS THE AUTHORITY COME
FROM?
HOW CAN THEY OVERRIDE THE
CONSTITUTION QUESTION MIKE
NOBODY SEEMS TO CARE.
THEY ARE TOO AFRAID.
BUT IF YOU THINK THIS MOMENT IS
SCARY, CONSIDER WHAT MIGHT COME
NEXT.
NOW THAT WE’VE CEDED ALL
AUTHORITY TO OUR POLITICAL
LEADERS, WHAT CAN’T THEY DO?
WHAT ARE THERE LIMITS TO THEIR
POWER?
THAT’S NOT A THEORETICAL
QUESTION.
IT’S NOT AN ARGUMENT OVER
PHILOSOPHY OR POLITICAL THEORY.
IT IS THE MOST PRACTICAL
POSSIBLE QUESTION.
THE ANSWER WILL DEFINE WHERE
THIS COUNTRY GOES NEXT.
WHAT CAN’T POLITICIANS DO IN THE
NAME OF PUBLIC HEALTH?
AS IT STANDS, POLITICIANS WON’T
LET PEOPLE WORSHIP, OR WORK, OR
GO TO SCHOOL, OR SEE THEIR AGING
PARENTS.
THEY PLACE A NATION UNDER HOUSE
ARREST.
THAT’S HAPPENING TODAY, RIGHT
NOW.
LET’S SAY WE ALL GET MORE
AFRAID.
WHAT THEN?
WHAT COULDN’T THEY START DOING?
COULD THEY TURN PEOPLE QUESTION
MIKE SEARCY.
YOU CAN DISMISS THE POSSIBILITY
IF YOU LIKE.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO MOST OF US
WOULD’VE DISMISSED IT LUDICROUS
THAT PROPAGANDA SPEWING DRONES
WOULD BE HOVERING ABOVE.
NOW WE HAVE ONE.
SO WHAT’S NEXT?